so of all the requests that I've had it
is surprising to realize that the thing
that has been probably the most
requested in the recent times has been
this storm area51 event that had was
created on Facebook and despite that
today is a sweltering day you probably
see me sweating as I talk about this I
will nonetheless try to explain how this
is related to certain patterns in
society
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so as you know the the storm area 51 is
a Facebook event which was created in
the late June as a joke you know as a
kind of spoof in order to - I think the
guy had did it had done it after he had
seen some area 51 guy on Joe Rogan
anyways it doesn't matter what is
hilarious is the fact that at this
moment I'm looking at over 3 million
people who have said they are either
going or interested in going and so a
lot of people have asked me why is it
that this particular thing has attracted
so much attention and the reason I'm
surprised that surprised that people
can't really see this because the reason
is that big it is connecting to certain
tropes now it's going to be difficult
for me to tell you what the meaning of
this is in the sense that because it is
a joke because it is a you know it's
just most of it is mostly for the memes
and to be on the inside of a certain
joke it would be strange if people
actually showed up for this event I'm
not saying it's not impossible that that
would happen but obviously it would be
very strange
now the reason why it is attracting so
much attention it is it's because you
could call it a mythological
representation a mythological version of
something which is happening all around
us of a trope in society which is going
on and so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to show you how it is the way that it's
framed is similar to other things going
on and maybe it can help you to
understand what exactly it's dealing
with now it shouldn't be so strange to
you that as this area 51 event is being
put on and as so many people are being
are getting involved in it or
participating in the joke there are
things that are less funny which are
happening at the same time and so we
have the story of this man who attacked
an ice facility in the US wanting to
free the the foreigners and this man was
killed by the police
you have you have activists like Shawn
King on Twitter who are saying who are
and Ocasio Cortez has also mentioned
that the detainment camps for Mexicans
crossing the border illegally are akin
to concentration camps and for example
Shawn kin says that the people in those
concentration camps should be liberated
now and he says by any means necessary
and so obviously that is a call to
violence a call to the type of action
that this man has done which is attacked
the ice facility and so what is it
that's going on obviously we can see
that the pattern of these events are the
same as the storm area51 that is there
is a place where we are keeping aliens
foreigners those two things are the same
in terms of symbolism and there are
others who want to free these these
foreigners from this this detainment
camp now the reason why the storm area51
event is so popular is that it is it is
really a almost a liturgical version
it's almost a like I said it's a
mythological version of the same pattern
which means that it's not necessarily
politically it's not on one side of the
political aisle
it's just picking up on this pattern and
then representing it in a in a science
fiction narrative narrative structure
now why is it that this question of the
aliens in area 51 to free them what's
the big deal what is it about and so
here's where we have to go back into my
explanation about the notion of the the
pattern of the alien the pattern of the
foreigner within a cosmic structure you
could say within an ontological
hierarchy that is we all have identities
that we identify with and as we look
further from our identity we encounter
something which is unknown I've often
said things like
it is insane to say that UFOs don't
exist
obviously UFOs exist they are
unidentified flying objects there are
akin to dragons or monsters they are
things that don't fit they are things
which manifest the unknown to us and so
the alien trope in our culture has come
to represent the epitome of that unknown
but in the ancient world this alien was
the foreigner and on in foreign races
you had monstrous races which could be
akin to the aliens today you had
monsters on the edge of the world but
you also had fantastical places you had
civilization this notion of the for
example in the stories of Alexander the
Great Alexander the Great
travels to the land of the brahman and
there he meets this idyllic culture of
people who don't even need clothing
they're just naked in nature and they're
completely at one with everything and
everybody they are peaceful and they
don't kill anything and and so it's like
this idyllic image of the foreigner and
so the foreigner because the foreigner
is unknown the foreigner will take two
sides will tend to be a space of
projection for both both the the worst
of us is the most animalistic the all
our vices all our excesses and then it
would also it will also be a place to
project our ideal this idea of purity or
of innocence and so we see the same in
the image of the immigrant today or the
image of the foreigner today we have the
same structure where one side of the
political aisle wants to portray the the
foreigners or immigrants or people from
the outside as possibly dangerous why
are they possibly dangerous because we
don't know who they are and so we don't
know what they are so they might be
dangerous and that is obviously true and
the other side wants to portray the
foreigner the immigrant as a resource as
as a new breath of fresh air which is
coming in and will increase our
possibilities will increase our
capacities for work or increase our
capacity for different cultural
understandings all of that is also
represented and that is also true to a
certain extent so both
are true to a certain extent but now in
this storm
area 51 you have this same idea you have
the idea especially in this storm of
year 51 you mostly have the idea that
these aliens are this ideal Society and
they have so much to give us they have
all this technology all this stuff that
they can give us and so they are like a
treasure and so the image of the alien
becomes like this treasure which is
being guarded by by the the government
by the authorities and so we're gonna go
in and we're going to access that ideal
thing you know that that that knowledge
that science that technology and it and
so it's not it's not that complicated
and so the reason like I said the reason
why so many people are willing to get
involved in it is because it is
represented a politically and so you
have on the one side I've seen
right-wing people get involved and use
their their tropes in the memes and then
I've also seen left-wing people get
involved and use their tropes in the
meme and so the meme is becomes a place
where where everybody can kind of come
together and and participate in this
social trope and exchange about this
social trope now if this also comes to
talk about what has been known in
Internet culture as this idea of meme
magic I haven't talked a lot about me
magic but I think it's maybe something
that is worth mentioning here that these
tropes these these memes that pop up
they also have a capacity to transform
the social sphere they have a capacity
to affect the world to change the way
people see things and and also to make
things happen and so that is usually
what people think about when they talk
about me magic and here in this storm
area 51 it is only one more one more
let's say part a little part of this
whole atmosphere of freeing the the
foreigners but it's not just that it's
also at the same time the the foreigners
who want
come in to the the United States and so
this idea of forcing the border of
breaking down the border and so all of
this is it's breaking down social order
to a certain extent that is the idea
that the government or any form and that
our society is there to hide something
from us
I've talked about this in my conspiracy
theory video is there to prevent us from
accessing certain things so all of this
is represented in this storm area51 meme
and so on the one hand going in getting
the foreigners but on the other hand the
foreigners coming in and getting access
to the advantages we have all of this is
contained and it doesn't have to be
rational because it is presented in this
this meme and story form it doesn't have
to be it doesn't at all have to be
presented in a in a rational manner it
can really be a kind of I hate to use
that word I guess with the mythopoetic
structure okay and it gives a way for
people to participate in so I hope this
is helping you to kind of understand why
this meme has been so popular and why so
many people from all different spheres
you know from the most edge Lorde
internet troll to you know was it
Budweiser had an area 51 cans and and
that song by that rapper and and what is
it
Old Town Road they did a video where
they play on this storming area 51 meme
and so all all aspects of society can
participate in this narrative trope
which is appearing in our society and
the the meme magic thing is going to be
interesting to see whether or not on
September 20th on the date that has been
given for this event whether or not
people will actually show up if they do
that would be a testimony to the
capacity for affecting the world through
memes so so guys I hope you enjoyed this
as you watch me sweat putting this
together and I will see all of you very
soon if you enjoy the symbolic world
content there's a lot of things you can
do to help us out if you're not
subscribed please do go ahead and share
this to all your friends
she can get involved in the discussion
we have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.ihaveaspergers.webs.com